Every week on our show
during the election process,
we like to talk to a different
segment of the American populous
to get their take
on this year's election.
Here to represent the small
but formidable voting block
of former presidents
of the United States of America
is former president of
the United States of America,
George W. Bush.
-(applause and cheering)
-(presidential fanfare plays)
(applause and cheering swell)
Nice to see you, Chris.
Nice to see you, too.
Thank you for coming.
How are you?
Glad to be here.
Nice to meet you.
You're a very distinguished
panel. Yeah.
Yeah. How are you?
How are you?
Had a...
-(applause and cheering)
-Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for coming,
Mr. President.
Very nice to have you here.
Hello, Chris.
Hello, my fellow Americans.
And hello, people of online,
especially...
especially @weedboner69.
(laughter)
He's a funny guy, Chris.
-You should have him on.
-All right, well,
we'll definitely consider that,
but I have to say,
it is a real honor
to have you on this program.
This legitimizes what we do
here. Thank you for coming.
Well, thank you. Thank you.
First of all, Chris,
I'd just like
to just say something
-about my cousin Billy Bush.
Uh... -(laughter)
He's been in the news a lot
lately, uh,
him and that disgraced pumpkin,
Donald Trump, uh,
talking on that bus.
And I... I just... I just want
to say one thing.
-We Bushes don't act like that,
okay? -(laughter)
We, uh... we have standards.
And we're, uh, we're raised
a certain way.
And we would never,
under any circumstances,
ride a bus.
You know, when
you're-when you're a Bush,
you ride in a limousine
or a Jumpjet.
Or maybe a monster truck
called Sasquatch Express.
But, uh, you know,
never a bus.
It-it boggles the mind.
Yeah, well, listen, there's
a very important distinction,
and I... you know,
it's too bad we didn't
find out about that earlier,
but a lot of Republicans
have come out
against Donald Trump, so...
People are confused
about where you stand.
Where do you stand?
Well, I'll tell you what,
Chris, uh,
this-this dunderhead is making
me look great, you know?
Yeah.
I mean, did-did you see
where I.. where I hugged
Michelle Obama a few weeks ago?
-You see that?
-Well, I...
I see where she's almost
kind of making a snarky face
and trying to hug you, but
you're not really giving back.
I mean, I'm-I'm kind
of affectionately
-leaning into her, like, "Aw..."
-Yeah, I guess maybe
a little bit, yeah, you're...
giving her a little lean,
but she's sort of...
I think we're both
feeling like, "This is nice."
I don't know if that...
I mean, the look on her face
is sort of like, "Can you
(bleep) believe this over here?"
I mean, it's, like, a little...
It seems... I...
You know what, though,
I don't want to take it away.
I guess it is a sweet moment,
it's a sweet moment.
Well... well, it was.
And, uh, I don't know why
you're-you're trying
to debunk it.
-It was a sweet moment.
-No, I'm not. I apo...
-Sorry, I apologize.
-And let's face it--
the Internet ate it up like a...
like a two-for-one deal
at the Cheesecake Factory.
Which, by the way,
is a good restaurant
with terrific snacks
and appetizers.
And I recommend
their cheesecake, Chris.
Oh, well.
Good recommendation.
Uh...
I mean, ev-everyone...
you go to Cheesecake Factory,
-why-why dick around, you know?
-Yeah, it's good. Don't...
-Just go right...
-Just go right to it,
-Just go right to it.
-Yeah, yeah. I mean...
-There's no reason...
-No, you're right,
you're absolutely right.
It's not...
It's not Chicken Factory
-or Steak Factory.
-Exactly.
-You're the only one
who gets it, man. -Yeah.
-I'm upset now.
-I mean, I...
That picture was so cute,
even I almost forgot
about how I invaded Iraq
over WMDs that weren't there.
I destabilized
an entire region, Chris,
but... but no one
seems to care anymore.
And, uh...
thanks to the-the bozo
Trump here,
uh, yeah,
folks have forgotten about
how I tanked the economy
or how I-I didn't
get bin Laden.
Heck, you know, Kanye West even
said I hated hurricanes.
But... all forgotten now.
-You know? -All gone.
Yeah, it's all good, so...
Okay, so, this is an
interesting thesis statement.
You're saying Trump
is improving your image.
So, does that... does that mean
that you're supporting him?
He-he's a-he's
a dangerous man, Chris.
And, uh, back in Texas,
where I'm from,
bo-born and raised...
you don't talk about women
the way he does.
We-we got a... got a funny
kind of justice down there.
Uh, some might even say
it's illegal.
But, uh, but if he ever
tried jammin' his
Tic Tac-covered cow tongue
down a lady's throat in Texas,
we'd give him what we call
the Amarillo steak and eggs.
That's where, uh,
that's where you cook him up
a nice T-bone steak,
medium rare,
with scrambled eggs
and a side of grits,
and then you drag him
with your truck.
-HARDWICK: Oh, okay. All right.
-Yeah.
Good to know.
That's just what...
That's how...
that's how they do it.
And now he's saying
the election's rigged.
The only thing that's rigged
is-is that stuffed chupacabra
on top of his head.
I don't know how
he keeps it on there,
but I-I sure hope
Hillary knocks it off.
-(cheering, applause) -Yeah.
-HARDWICK: Oh. Oh, well, that...
Okay, that's...
that's really interesting.
So that-so that means
you're endorsing Hillary, then?
Well, I... well, eh... I...
Look... I'm not
the decider, Chris.
Yeah, I know, but I just...
I feel like so many Bushes
have already
indicated their support,
including your daughter
Barbara Bush,
your wife Laura Bush,
your father and former president
George H.W. Bush,
Gavin Rossdale,
the lead singer of Bush,
the dog from
the Bush's Baked Beans ad,
almost every roller coaster
operator at Busch Gardens,
this Bush near the I-80
outside Akron.
So... what about
this last square here?
What about George W. Bush? Are
you endorsing Hillary?
What are you doing?
-Look at my wife's hat.
-Well...
That wa... I-I was
asking if you're...
-She looks almost Britishy,
you know? -Yeah, yeah, she...
She-she looks very Britishy,
but I-but I was asking
-who you're supporting, and...
-I'm sorry, Chris,
-I wasn't paying attention.
I was just... -Okay.
...meresmerized by my...
She... It look like
she'd be part of the cast
-of Downton Abbey. -Yeah, she
does. Yeah, she definitely...
looks like the cast
of Downton Abbey.
I-Is it a hat that you would
think maybe a president
that you might want to see
in the White House
would wear, or...
I still don't know
what you're driving towards.
-Uh...
-Okay, all right.
I'll take world history for 400.
All right.
Fair.
Very fair. Okay.
World history it is.
In the 2016
presidential election,
George W. Bush
endorsed this candidate.
Look, Chris...
if Trump takes this thing,
Laura and I have
a very comfortable
underground bunker
we can move to, okay?
It's got a mini fridge
for snacks and sodas
and a much larger
walk-in freezer
with thousands
of Hungry-Man dinners.
Uh, we have every season
of Just Shoot M on DVD,
so I'm gonna be down there
with, uh, Princess Kate
and Nolan Ryan
while society gets overrun
by wild dogs and racists.
My advice is
don't let that happen, America.
Don't let that
sack of rotten sweet potatoes
anywhere near the White House,
you know?
-HARDWICK: All right, so...
-(cheering, applause)
I mean, those are
very strong words.
So, that's a yes for Hillary?
Truth be told, I have...
I have a-a strict
no-endorsement policy
since I got burned on a deal
before I was governor of Texas.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I remember that.
I mean, I loved...
I loved them dang pants.
-Yeah. -It's hard not to, and
you now you have a lot of 'em.
President George W. Bush, thank
you so much for being here.
Uh, do you have time to stick
around and play a game with us
-after the break?
-Of course I've got time.
-What-what do you think
I'm doing here, Chris? -Okay.
-(cheering, applause)
-All... all I have...
Yeah.
I mean, literally,
all I have is time.
I mean, you're gonna be lucky
if I even leave today.
Okay, well, I...
I'm glad you're sticking around.
We're happy to have you here.
We'll be right back with
former president George W. Bush
and more @midnight.
Stick around.